it's two years now since the referendum
and last year last July you said that
the brexit deal should be one of the
easiest in human history so how do you
think it's going well what I'm saying
was that the trade part of it should be
technically easy because we already have
full regulatory and legal alignment with
the EU but of course this was never
going to be just about trade it's mostly
about politics it's about the politics
of the European Union and that is the
complicating factor in all of this
so they playing more horrible than you
expected them know I think that the the
European Commission in the first part of
the negotiation we're always going to
represent the interests of the 27 in a
way that was fairly consistent they were
worried about the money the citizens
rights and so on I think the second part
of the negotiation which is about the
economic part will be much more diverse
in terms of European views because the
countries have different trading
relationships with the United Kingdom
and and will want to a greater or lesser
extent to protect that and now I'm keen
to touch on Boris Johnson's article that
he wrote this weekend as well a book
roll breakfast in his very colorful
language a warning of a kind of
political no-man's-land if you like
we're we're half in and half out he's
right isn't he
we're not heading towards the kind of
bricks that the new always dreamed of
either are we well what I wanted was
that we were outside the single market
in the customs union and we were outside
the jurisdiction of the European Court
of Justice that's where I think we're
going to end up if we do it slightly
more slowly in order to minimize any
disruption that's fine by me you know
having waited 40 odd years to leave the
European Union a few extra months it
doesn't bother me if if we're getting it
right and I think it was really
important that we we get that that dual
right for Britain and we get it right
for Europe and I think that what's
what's really key to all of this is is
it a political brexit or is it an
economic brexit for the people of Europe
that's the decision that needs to be
made in the next few months it's
interesting listening to you because on
the one hand you got Boris Johnson
warning about book war exits and you've
got yourself sound doing you know very
diplomatic very reasonable and it kind
of feels interesting because it feels to
music when your first appointment
appointed you're almost seen as the
ability brexit here you know the kind of
risk brexit err if you like but actually
compared to Boris Johnson and David
Davis you'll perhaps the best behave
well we've got a big department to run
we've got to think about what happens
after brexit and you know it's we really
focus on of the world outside Europe and
part of this whole debate part of the
problems been that it's very Eurocentric
and if you look at for example at
britain's trade only 43% of our trade
now goes to the european union where ten
years ago it was 57% the rest of the
world's growing more quickly we need to
think about Britain's place in the rest
of the world and and not regard Europe
as the center of the world
at the same time you kind of feel as if
Boris Johnson and David Davis are
shaping brexit Boris Johnson by writing
these newspaper columns trying to swing
government policy David Davis by
threatening to resign if his red lines
aren't met do you not need to be a
little bit more bullish yourself do you
think are you doing that in private well
I was being told yesterday that I was
being too bullish by saying that the
Prime Minister wasn't bluffing when she
said that no deal was a possibility you
know we there we have to balance a
number of things one is we need to be
pragmatic about how we actually achieve
our exit the other is to remind our
European partners that we're not kidding
that we would walk away rather than
accept a bad deal for Britain is that
true would you really walk away over the
No Deal sorry yes I think as I've said
before our European partners would be
foolish to believe that because the
Prime Minister is very considered very
very pragmatic that she's bluffing
none of us including me want No Deal I
sincerely hope we get a good deal and I
think that's in the interests of the
European Union as much as the United
Kingdom but if politics is put ahead of
the economic well-being and the
long-term well-being of the United
Kingdom we would have to walk away I
just don't think that's going to happen
because I think ultimately the elected
governments that depend upon trade and
prosperity and growth and jobs are not
going to to put the ideology of the
European Commission ahead of the
prosperity of their own people but
same time it's also not gonna happen
because you haven't got a parliamentary
majority for either happiness Oh No Deal
isn't gonna happen if you're being
completely honest is it well you know if
we if we if we have not got a deal it's
good for Britain if there's attempts to
hold us inside the customs union or the
single market when the people of Britain
decided to vote against it then we'd
have to we'd have to have No Deal listen
she's saying this in a week where Airbus
BMW of wound of absolutely catastrophic
consequences if there are no deal and
think hang on you're the one putting
politics ahead of the economics no no
what we've said is we we want there to
be a deal and it's in the interest of
everybody that there's a deal so why
don't you just take this no deal
scenario off the table we haven't got a
parliamentary majority for it the UK is
not ready for it look at David the
preperations hadn't been done
companies like Airbus are saying that
they're prepared to delay investment or
just not invest in the UK if it happens
so just to safeguard the jobs and
investment in the UK just take off the
table because it's a negotiation if we
actually say will accept any deal you
give us rather than walk away that
weakens our negotiating position and
people who are making these comments
need to understand that they may
actually be putting the UK to
disadvantage by making these cases we've
got to be free in a negotiation to say
if we don't get the deal that we want
there won't be any agreement so do you
think that companies like
Airbus or indeed MPs who are pushing for
the No Deal scenario to be taken off the
table are actually putting the
prosperity Elisabeth I think that
companies are right to say that if
there's no deal that would be good for
Britain but it won't be good for Europe
either because I don't point out at the
point I make to them is that they should
also be meeting the same case to
European governments that that will be
bad for them in an era where we've got
complex integrated supply chains it will
be necessarily bad for both sides it's
clear that you're sticking to opposition
on there no deal so let's see if we can
get a bit of clarity in other areas can
you rule out any extension to article 15
I think to keep Britain in the European
Union would not be politically
acceptable wouldn't be acceptable to me
so no extensions article 50 well I mean
I wouldn't find that
Eliska accepts all that can support it
something that you might resign over
well
everyone keeps saying you know what
you do if this happens I'm saying it's
not politically acceptable to me and how
about an extension of the transition
period well if the transition period and
had to be extended for technical reasons
as we've discussed with the backstop if
for example one other country or was he
unable to ratify an agreement or we'd
enough technical means in place and we
already had the transition and we
already had the withdrawal agreement and
the future economic partnership already
agreed I wouldn't have a major problem
with that as long as it was very time
limited and there was a unilateral
mechanism for Britain to pull out of it
if we thought that we were being kept in
the European Union against our will so
actually you could see a scenario if it
was a time-limited extension to the
transition if it was time limited and
Britain had a unilateral mechanism to
end it what we couldn't accept was any
extension to the implementation period
that was under the control of Brussels
not under the control of London another
big risk of course the brexit is what's
happening in America this kind of trade
war if you like this seems to be at risk
of being launched by I Donald Trump are
you confident still that the UK will get
a good deal with the u.s. after
president well you have to separate out
the two things and also done by two
different bits of the US government our
discussions on future trading agreements
with the United States are based on our
mutual interests you know what would be
good for both sides we don't think that
the the tariffs being applied by the
United States are in the interests of
both sides so that's a separate a
separate issue I spent the last couple
of days in Geneva at the World Trade
Organization there is real concern that
this could damage the global economy if
you start getting restrictions on trade
applied by both sides on an
ever-escalating basis then you will get
potentially real damage to that global
economy that will do much more harm to
to Britain than any thing that could
come out of the brexit process if that
were unsuccessful this is a genuine
threat to global growth and that for a
country like Britain that is an open
trading country could be extremely
damaging so we still hope that we can
roll back from this we understand a lot
of the analysis at the United States
make them about Chinese overproduction
about our problems with market entry
forced technology transfer and so on we
also understand why the the u.s. is
upset with NATO countries not carrying
the share of defense spending and of
course when Britain leaves the European
Union we will that brings that into
sharp focus because when we leave the
European Union EU NATO members will be
carrying less than 20 percent of the
NATO budget which is absurd I understand
all of those things but the way of going
about it is not to apply tariffs have
you had any assurances about tariffs in
the UK well of course we are affected by
that by being members of the European
Union but we'll continued be members of
the European Union but when we leave
when we leave the European Union do you
think that we still we have these
tariffs not this is not this is not a
European issue and we have to try to
stop seeing everything through a brexit
lens this is a unilateral action carried
out and what we believe is in breach of
World Trade Organization rules we
believe in that rules based system and
we will stand up for that and the
concept of free trade and therefore if
we are forced into the position of
taking countermeasures in WTO law then
we will do so and when it comes to trade
deals of course and it won't it's not
just the u.s. that we're looking at in
the future it's lots of other countries
around the world a big growth economies
like India for example would you be
prepared to see a new relaxation of the
visa requirements on these countries if
it meant that we'd be getting good
traders with them well a movement of
people is always one of the things
that's considered in any trade agreement
and that would be something that we
would look at in in a bilateral
negotiation but remember it is a
negotiation and you don't give your
cards away at the beginning of that but
you in any trade negotiation you have to
recognize you're looking at a whole
range of factors and when you get into
those negotiations you decide both sides
will decide you know what's on the table
and what's off the table so that's
that's a long way away but it's on the
table it's it's a long way away because
we are currently not looking at a free
trade agreement with India in the near
future we're engaged in a discussion
with India on a trade review we were
looking sector-by-sector at our
economies to see how we could get to
within a closing distance that might
enable us have
we trade agreement but we're not there
yet okay and now I want to move on to a
couple of other issues just before we
and one of those is those difficult
votes that we saw in the House of
Commons and over the meaningful vote now
one of the things that will stick in
people's minds I think as a site of Nash
are in a wheelchair with a sick bucket
because conservatives decided not to
allow her to be simply nodded through
they wanted her to be in the house in
the Commons chamber voting there was a
medical man does that not worry well the
Labour Party make those decisions about
who they bring in themselves and and the
whips make decisions amongst themselves
in how that voting is going to go on
I've seen that before I've seen it when
John Major had had no majority then
Labour Party for the Labour Party I
remember the Liberal Party at that time
bringing people conserved to him he's
having to come in by ambulance and from
hospital to vote it was a ridiculous
system later I think I think too much
rational people that is a ridiculous
system when I think that we need to find
ways to make up to make that more
acceptable is there a worry as well that
you're kind of losing the viral war if
you like you know forget the kind of
very important kind of intricacies of
the meaningful vote what a lot of people
will remember is the sight of that woman
in the wheelchair and it's similar to
the upskirting you know being blocked by
chrystopher truth is there a risk that
because you're losing that kind of viral
campaign to labour you could be seen as
the nasty party again no I don't think
that's true I think what people will
remember was that there was a very
vibrant vote that both houses considered
the withdrawal bill and the government
ultimately succeeded in delivering what
we're there for which is to carry out
the voters instruction to leave the
European Union
another vibrant provoke coming off of
course is the trade bill that could be a
difficult one for the government so if
there is the boat on staying in a
customs union if the government loses
she might be out of a job
well the trade bill is there to ensure
continuity of our current trading
arrangements it also is there to ensure
that we have the ability to set up a
trade remedies body to defend things
like our steel industry are a ceramics
industry people who played games with
this need to understand the consequences
would be a disruption to our trade and
an inability
for us to defend parts of our industry
against dumping from places like China
before they start to a parliamentary
games they should think about the
consequences for real British jobs is
that message to some of your own back
benches as well it's a message to
everybody we'll be voting on that bill
and then just finally we've got a vote
on Heathrow Airport coming up of course
the expansion that is Heathrow Airport
Boris Johnson is conveniently gonna be
after the country do you think it's one
more for him and one more for everyone
else well you know the Foreign Secretary
is regularly out of the country are
probably only the only person more than
myself who's required to be away to do
their job well I happen to be there but
I was a wee last week I'll be there here
we are in the southwest of England it's
hugely in our interest here as I believe
in the rest of the country that we get
further expansion at Heathrow we need
more airport capacity we've got too few
links at the moment to places like China
we can only do that by improving the
capacity he throws one of our biggest
ports by value from a trading
perspective we need to get that new
runway built and soon and there are
those not a few of them I have to say
around the world who wonder why ticks
are so long in this country to make big
decisions about our infrastructure